NAT: Hello, JSConf EU.
My name is Nat Alison and I'm going to make
all of you fall in love with polyhedra.
Your first question is, what is a polyhedron.
It's a solid in three dimensions with flat
faces, sharp corners or verity seize.
For example, some of you may know of the platonic
solid, the cube in the tetrahedron, they have
a single type of face and are really symmetric.
So whichever way you turn them, you get the
same figure.
And the relatives, the Archimedean solids,
they're highly symmetric and you can rotate
and get the same shape.
And the Johnson solids which can be made of
any regular polygon in whatever order.
These can range from a simple square pyramid
to a triangular habesphenorotunda.
Anyways, I love polyhedra.
And I'm not the only one.
They have been used in art and architecture
and games and films for centuries.
They're beautiful and symmetrical and found
in nature.
They're simple, but somehow extremely alien
to us.
But there's another reason that I like them.
And it has to do with Pokemon.
And this isn't really it's kind of silly but
not really.
Both polyhedra and Pokemon have data associated
with them.
Polyhedra have symmetries, Pokemon have different
sets and rarities.
There's like a butt load of each of them.
Of a lot of unique polyhedra in Pokemon to
discover and that involve in different ways.
The Pokemon just gets bigger and stronger.
And sometimes can branch off and become two
different Pokemon or more.
But with polyhedra, it's more difficult.
You can do this weird twisty thing, snubification.
And when I was a kid, I spent hours poring
over websites looking at models in VR and
origami which was really fun but also made
me kind of sad.
The thing was, lots of people love and know
about Pokemon, me included.
In fact, I loved Pokemon so much that the
first thing I did in Europe was catch one
in Pokemon, it's a regional exclusive.
I just had to.
But not as many people know about polyhedra
and that's kind of a shame and sad.
I wanted to make the best polyhedra website
that ever was.
To have my quest and understand them as my
cause.
Today I'm going to share my journey to becoming
a polyhedra master.
But before that, before talking about code.
Let's talk about the other ways that I tried
to bring my love of polyhedra to life.
I went through several attempts.
The first of which is origami.
It's cool and artsy and I thought, why not
make my own?
I made one cube and I got a paper cut and
didn't want to do it anymore.
I got tired quickly.
I thought, maybe I could 3D print them and
make cool jewelry.
You know, 3D printing technology advanced
a lot.
You need to upload a model and, oh, my god,
it's too expensive.
The next step which followed was writing polyhedra
fan fiction.
[ Laughter ]
But less said about that phase, the better.
And after this I decided you know what?
Let me just make a website.
That's what I know how to do.
So, I got started.
Our journey begins in May 2015.
I was working as an internal tools engineer
making code for engineers who make code for
engineers who make code for other people.
It felt like a Pikachu in the generator just
grinding away.
So, wait.
So, I asked my boss, I really wanted to do
frontend and I asked him, can I work on frontend
stuff.
And eventually he got back to me and said
well, you know, I heard you like this.
We have a new project coming up.
I have just the thing for you, Jenkins.
[ Laughter ]
It's a UI.
You should work on that.
Needless to say, I was not very happy with
this, so I decided to take matters into my
own hands.
And what better way to do that than by making
something that I already love.
When I started, I had a bunch of big brain
ideas about collecting every single fact about
polyhedra in Wikipedia and putting them on
my page, I wanted to do VR.
I wanted to do cool transformations, transforming
them into once another.
And I still had my job going Jenkins.
In Pokemon, before you challenge the elite
four, you have to get your first gym badge.
That's what I did.
I narrowed it down to an updated version of
the sites that hi loved as a kid where I could
see my favorite polyhedra.
I downloaded from one of my favorite websites.
JS was a little too low level and I didn't
to want struggle with lighting and buffers.
But I knew D3 and the data binding model and
I found a library, xFreedom, letting me express
3D modelling data as dominoes like D3.
It worked perfectly.
It took me about a week of part time work
to get it working.
And I'll just bring this over here.
And you can see I have a little tetrahedron.
A cube.
An Archimedean solid.
Different Johnson solids.
But that was kind of it.
Let me close this out.
I showed that to a few friends, but kind of
left.
it was a good start, but also too simple and
not really interactive and I found myself
being unsatisfied by it.
Fast forward two years later, I got fired
because I hated Jenkins.
I took a sabbatical and wrote a video game
and more science fiction and started a job
with frontend.
It was Angular 1, but baby steps.
I did that and we were in the process of switching
out our frontend from Angular to React and
I thought that I should be a good employee
and learn about it in a side project.
But I didn't want to do the basic TD app that
everyone does with learning a new frontend
framework.
So, I thought, why not make my old polyhedra
viewer into React.
After all, Nintendo has been making the same
Pokemon game for decades and we love them.
I got started.
And it turns out that React as a framework,
it works really well with X3 DOM just like
D3.
Moreover, I found that React was easier to
add in reactivity such as a configuration
panel or a search bar or an index page where
you can see my collection at once.
And I don't have a live version of this running.
But I showed it to my boss and teammates and
that was it.
Oh, get back to work.
It was more interactive, but still esthetic.
You can change the colors but doesn't tell
you about polyhedra.
What I wanted was the cool transitions, but
I didn't have time because I was busy refactoring
an Angular app, so I had to put it away again.
Fast forward another couple of months.
And in October, left my job due to burnout
and depression and kind of just wanted to
take a break from all the coding and focus
on my other hobbies.
Like fan fiction.
But somehow writing polyhedra fan fiction
did not make me forget about polyhedra.
And old habits die hard and I kept coming
back to the polyhedra and making improvements
to it.
More specifically, I wanted to arrange the
polyhedra into sort of a periodic table based
on their properties.
And seeing all the polyhedra related to each
other and correlating it like that made me
think, why not just do what I wanted to do
in the first place?
I finally feel I have the skills to do it,
and more importantly, I have the time.
I got started on the long, laborious process
of finally making the final evolution of my
polyhedra viewer.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
But the very first step was to determine what
operations were possible and actually valid.
After all, not over Pokemon can evolve or
combine into one another.
And you don't want to allow free form combinations
in polyhedra as cool as they might look.
I had the relations for the periodic table.
And when you see lines connecting dots like
this, you're looking at a state machine or
a graph with the polyhedra's notes and the
operations at the edges.
And there's a pretty straight forward to represent
this as an object.
You can it's just like an object of an object
of a list of objects.
You just label it with metadata to differentiate
between multiple results.
But there's a lot of polyhedra and a lot of
relationships to encode.
And it's all really but luckily, it's all
really structured.
And through an advanced programming technique
called foreloops, we can save time from manually
coding the entire graph.
Okay.
Now that we have this graph, we can figure
out what configurations and options to transfer
a polyhedra to another one.
And you can disable operations, if they're
invalid.
You can test whether an operation leads to
a result that matches the model that we currently
have.
You can mock the applications and click the
next polyhedron instead of animating them.
Now that we have that out of the way, let's
talk about the transitions.
At the beginning, I didn't know what I was
doing and how many operations or what I wanted.
So, it would be nice to have an abstract interface
that I can plug in.
Hi to think to myself, what is a transition?
Think about what we're doing.
We're interpolating verities from a start
to an end.
The faces and edges are defined by the Vertices.
They don't change even if they're invisible
at some point or overlap.
But there's a problem with doing duplication.
And that's that we want to be able to chain
operations like this.
We want to be able to blow stuff up and contract
stuff.
And it would be too complicated to keep track
of all the due my cushions for every operation.
And we have the switch, and it's hard to see
which is which, it's impossible to tell the
duplicate, but one has extra vertices and
faces.
And we can define an interface.
And as long as the functions return the interface,
we can animate all of them the same way.
And the algorithm is one, replace the vertices
with the duplicated versions, and interpolate
and switch out the end result with the D duplicated
version.
This is kind of what it looks like in code.
We have the state function, set it to the
start and interpolate and set it to the D
duplicated end.
And finally, you need an interpolation function.
There's a lot of libraries you can use for
animation in JavaScript.
Half don't exist anymore because animation
in JavaScript is a crap shoot.
Or you can Google and roll out your own.
It's great.
We don't have anything to test it on, though.
So, let's talk about the actual operations
we're going to make.
I'm not going to go over all of them.
But I wanted to share one example that's kind
of easy and it's this operation called rectify.
You have this shape, a cuboctahedron.
And you have the cube and draw the points
and draw lines and cut them up and slice them
up.
But we don't want to go back and forth, we
want a smooth transition.
In order to get the smooth transition, to
animate it, we duplicate each twice so there
are three vertices at each corner.
Pull them to the midpoints and if there are
two sets of vertices, we consolidate them
into one.
The algorithm is just duplicate and then map
to the end.
The duplication is annoying and not interesting.
It's making sure that the old stuff maps to
the new stuff and allow cross referencing
vertices.
Finding the vertex is just picking the one
that is not one of your duplicates and calculating
the midpoint through a map library.
And finally, you put it all together and return
the interface that we just defined.
And here we go.
Squash and stretch.
[ Applause ] that really wasn't that impressive.
I don't know why you all are clapping.
So, I think I made about half the operation
before realizing, math is kind of hard, y'all.
In particular, the way that you usually represent
polyhedral geometry is through a list of coordinates
and a list of faces that refer to the indices
of the vertices that are in the faces.
Which is fine for 3D modelling, but that doesn't
always translate well to the math stuff we
want to do.
How you combine two polyhedra together?
Or the selected faces of the polyhedra, it's
hard.
And what you end up doing is a lot of index
manipulation.
The face indices, you have indices of indices.
And I'm so tired of indices.
Did you know the plural of index is indices?
Now I do.
How to solve this problem?
Different types of Pokemon are strong against
each other.
If you're fighting a water Pokemon, use an
electric Pokemon, that's what's effective.
And different types of programming have different
solutions.
In this case, the solution we're going to
use is object oriented programming.
They have their weaknesses, but useful here.
You can, of course, encapsulate method in
the polyhedra like getting a centroid or combining
two together.
And you can keep track of metadata like the
custom data like vector format that the vertices
are stored in.
And in particular this is there's a really
useful structure called a doubly connected
edge list.
It's a link list where each face has links
to adjacent facets, and it was easy to do
with the class structure.
I could have stopped at making the polyhedron
class.
They could stop with Pokemon, but then Nintendo
couldn't make money with the Pokemon.
I made everything a class, the edges, the
faces, I have no idea if that was a good idea
or not.
But didn't have to see the word indices again
so I was happy.
But even with this, it was hard.
For example, determining a solid.
Sometimes they do different things depending
on platonic or Archimedean.
And you can see if they have the same, and
there's this asshole, an elongated structure,
it looks like an Archimedean solid, but it's
annoying and it's like the Mr. Mime of polyhedra.
And to do it right is more involved.
How to solve this problem.?
In Pokemon, there's a mythical Pokemon called
Mu that you can only get in Tokyo.
But when I played the first Pokemon game,
I couldn't go to Tokyo because I was 8 years
old.
You can use this glitch to get the Mu much
easier.
Let's just cheat.
We know there are only 13 Archimedean solid
known since the Renaissance, it's proven.
Since we have the list, why not just list
them all and check if it's one of those.
And this turns out making these shortcuts
was actually a lot really useful in a lot
of areas because there are a lot of places
where it's significantly easier to code when
you know what thing you're turning into when
you have the graph.
Anyways, that's a lot of math.
So, let's go focus on art.
Like I said in the beginning, a lot of these
polyhedra sites are really old.
They're often done by math professors on their
spare time.
For example, this is kind of the state of
the art of polyhedra websites.
I took this screenshot not in 1995, but two
weeks ago.
They're so old a lot don't work anymore.
You can't see the polyhedra models or view
or upload them.
I wanted my website to be a new destination
for polyhedra lovers.
I wanted it to work on mobile phones so you
could play with it anywhere.
Or if you don't have access to a desktop.
I wanted to make sure that there are a lot
of visual aids so you can press around on
the buttons even if you don't know what they
do or know the math.
And I made sure to pass the site even if you
have a bad connection or a disability or you
don't have Wi Fi on a plane and need screenshots
for your talk at JSConf EU.
So, after much work, I was ready to present
it.
So, here is the polyhedra viewer.
Here is the home page.
You have the periodic table of polyhedra showing
all of them.
Let's start out with a simple tetrahedron.
You can truncate it.
Sharpen it.
You can augment it.
Or diminish it.
You can do that operation that we coded together
called rectification.
And you can do that animation where you expand
the polyhedron.
And you can contract it back until it's a
cube.
And finally, you can do this weird thing called
snubification.
And you can see it's expanding the faces,
but it's like twist them.
And you can also search and filter.
Change the colors.
The color thing is like on my other screen.
Or look at info about each polyhedron.
Anyways, the link is up over there.
And so, you can just play around with it instead
of listening to me for the rest of the talk.
Ah.
So, I kind of released it and expected it
to just sync.
After all, polyhedra are really obscure and
the last couple of times I just showed it
to friends and they were like, that's nice.
Get back to work.
But to my surprise, a lot of people loved
it.
A lot of people I admired in the development
community Retweeted it.
I got interviewed we math publications.
I was able to connect with a lot of people
both in the tech and art and math space who
really enjoyed it.
I had parents telling me their kids can't
stop playing with it.
Teachers telling me they want to use it to
teach about polyhedron in the classroom.
I was able to learn about other polyhedra
projects by others obsessed with aspects of
polyhedra.
And I was able to connect with artists who
loved polyhedra and expressed it in a different
way through their art.
But at the end of my long, long journey, the
message that I want to impart is, even if
you think your passions are too obscure or
weird, there's always a way to share it with
the world and make other people fall in love
with them as well.
No matter if it's polyhedra or Pokemon.
And it's okay to take your time to evolve
and grow whatever your passions are to transform
them.
And eventually I'm sure that you can create
something amazing.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]